في هذه الصور يظهر اجور كولوموسكي
الملياردير الاوكراني والمشتبه باختلاف
مبلغ مليار يورو في قضيه تتعلق بشركات
النفطيه السلطات الاوكرانيه اعلنت تفتيش
منزله في اطار تحقيقات فساد تستهدف عده
شخصيات اخرى من بينهم وزير الداخليه
السابق ارسين او نائب وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني السابق
الاسبوع الماضي
لقد مارس ضغوطا عده من اجل الحصول على
عقود معدات عسكريه منخفضه الجوده لكن كان
يسجل شرائها باسعار مرتفعه جدا وصلت الى
اكثر من 25 مليون يورو الرئيس الاوكراني
رحب بتحقيقات مكافحه الفساد
هذا اليوم مهم لبلدنا فهو يوم مثمر في
معركتنا ضد اولئك الذين يحاولون اضعاف
اوكرانيا لن نسمح لاي شخص باضعاف دولتنا
سيتم تحقيق العداله
في خضم الحرب يريد فولودي اظهار حزمه في
محاربه الفساد فكيف تعتمد بشكل كبير على
المساعدات الماليه الغربيه الاتحاد
الاوروبي جعل مكافحه الفساد شرطا لانضمام
اوكرانيا الى التكتل وطالب بضمانات
للاستمرار في دعمها في حربها ضد روسيا ملف
ستتم مناقشته خلال قمه تستضيفها كياف
للطرفين يوم الجمعه